[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur cellestis
ich war ja neulich mit murat in brüssel
und hab da ein großes dessert buffet
gemacht und viele von euch haben gefragt
menschen die macht von denn zum riesen
der sap jetzt gerade für silvester oder
für veranstaltungen geburtstage und in
diesem video zeige ich euch ein paar
tipps und tricks wir das machen könnt
wie es ansehnlich aussieht aber eben
auch wenig arbeit ist und ich habe jetzt
vor einfach drei verschiedene
komponenten zu machen einmal einen
mississippi maathai das ist so die
schokoladige komponente einen rahmen
kuchen da ist schön cremig und einen
cupcake dazu den mississippi maffay und
den raum kuchen habe ich bereits
gebacken
da gibt es ja schon rezepte auf einem
kanal da könnt ihr einfach ein großes
gleich backen
am tag vorher auch gerne schon und dann
habt ihr wirklich schon eine riesengroße
menge geschafft jetzt habe ich hier noch
den cupcakes part und dafür zeige ich
euch mal die zutaten für den teig für
den teig nämlich 300 gramm zucker eine
prise salz 440 gramm mehl einen
teelöffel backpulver und einen halben
teelöffel natron feier etwas vanille
extrakt jeweils 300 gramm sonnenblumenöl
und buttermilch ihr könnt aber auch
mineralwasser nehmen und 100 gramm weiße
schokolade ich spalte dieses thema auf
in trockenen zutaten und flüssige zu
haben und ich habe ich jetzt noch die
schokolade
da hab ich jetzt ne kuvertüre die wir
jetzt fein gehackt
[Musik]
und jetzt versuche ich jeden der
schüssel die flüssigen zu tragen
etwas vanille extrakt es wirklich ganz
kurz verhören dass ich alles schön
verbunden hat und hier könnte die
trockenen zutaten verrühren also so dass
sich wirklich mädel backpulver
vermischen
jetzt kommt alles sehen die schüssel und
hätte nur noch verrührt und das war auch
schon so einfach gehen cupcakes ok
zumindest datei und ihr könnt hier gerne
auch abwandlungen machen das ist jetzt
meine variation ihr könnt aber auch
schoko muffins machen oder noch
schokostückchen mit rein geben oder
gefrorene himbeeren oder was auch immer
er möchte und das ist jetzt echt eine
große menge also ihr werdet hier aus
schon locker war 70-80 cupcakes schreibt
sich später in einem blog und wenn jetzt
nicht so viele machen wollte macht ein
paar tischen des rezepts weiß müssten
sogar knapp 100 sein denn die hälfte des
rezepts ist für zwei bleche also für 48
ja dann sind es knapp 100 gibt es
nämlich einfach ein eis portionierer hat
hier ein mini muffin form und fülle die
jetzt zu drei viertel mit dem teig
[Musik]
ich hab hier genau vier bleche voll
bekommen also 96 muffins und die kommen
jetzt gleichzeitig in den backofen also
ich habe zwei backöfen deswegen kann
sich alle vier blöcke gleichzeitig
backen ansonsten macht ihr am besten die
hälfte des rezepts denn zwei stück
können in einen backofen und dann macht
ihr noch weil das rezept wenn er
überhaupt so viele machen wollen die
backe ich jetzt mehr heißluft 180 grad
und nach dem abkühlen geht es direkt
weiter in der zwischenzeit kann ich aber
schon mal die soße dafür machen die wird
nämlich auch lecker
[Musik]
die muffins gebacken und abgekühlt jetzt
geht es direkt weiter
ich mache es diese soße dafür nämlich
jetzt himbeeren aus dem tiefkühlfach
das ist 600 gramm ich mache ist echt
eine große menge ihr könnt natürlich
auch weniger machen
da kommt jetzt der zucker dazu und wenn
ihr wollt könnt ihr hier noch gewürze
dazugeben wie zimt sternanis zitronen
april oder auch ein bisschen konto oder
himbeergeist ich lasse es jetzt so pur
lasst das ganze aufkochen und zerdrückt
auch gleich hier mit dem programm
so bekommt es gleich eine drahtige
konsistenz und nach dem kochen werde ich
dann aber durch ein sieb streichen damit
die kerne entfernt werden
dann habe ich eine leckere himbeer soße
[Musik]
jetzt geht es weiter mit den muffins die
bekommen jetzt eine baisse haube die wir
sehr haube ist doch wirklich ideal für
ein büfett
denn die machen müssen dann nicht mehr
in den kühlschrank das heißt man hat
einfach keinen platz verbrauch im
kühlschrank kann sie bei raumtemperatur
stehen lassen die zerfall nicht diese
fließen nicht und sie schmecken einfach
lecker normalerweise würde ich dazu noch
dessen frucht kein rein machen aber ich
habe später etwas anderes vor also mache
ich jetzt keinen frucht kann und die
soße dazu ich brauche dafür jetzt nur
drei zutaten eiweiß zucker und vanille
extrakt und entweder arbeitet in der
küchenmaschine mit hitze funktion oder
über einem heißen wasserbad auf dem herd
wichtig ist jetzt nämlich dass das
eiweiß mit dem zucker verrührt wird und
dann für mindestens zehn minuten lang
über dem kochenden wasserbad erwärmt
wird dabei natürlich ständig rühren am
besten mit einem handrührgerät oder eben
einfach in der küchenmaschine auf 70
grad erhitzen und da auch zehn minuten
hören damit zum einen die eismeister
schön stabil wird und wirklich auch
standfest bleibt aber zum anderen auch
keime abgetötet werden
und nach dem erhitzen also nach dem zehn
minuten rühren auf dem heißen wasserbad
oder mit hitze schaltet die hitze
abnehmen es also vom wasserbad runter
und dann wird es kalt gerührt damit
schön stabil wird
[Musik]
weiter geht's mit den cupcakes die masse
ist jetzt fest
und da gebe ich jetzt noch etwas vanille
extrakt dazu ihr könnt die masse jetzt
also diese marshmallow masse die bisher
masse verfeinern wie ihr möchtet ihr
könnt auch ein schlückchen rum dazu
geben oder rum aroma oder alles was sie
hat gerne tun haben wollte tom karonga
ist auch sehr lecker
ich mache jetzt aber war neben rein und
es kommt jetzt hier in meinem
spritzbeutel und habe ich bereits eine
fein gezackte stern tolle daran eine
kleine denn ich habe ja auch mir lieber
fleisch gibt jetzt mehrere möglichkeiten
entweder spritzt der db maße hier drauf
und tod später die cupcakes in
schokolade dann habt ihr wie so eine art
cupcakes oder ihr nehmt diese himberg
füllung die mittlerweile abgekühlt ist
ich habe jetzt mit einer fülle hier in
einen spritzbeutel gefüllt füllt den
kapek damit und dann kommt erst bei sie
drauf das problem ist wenn er die filme
verwendet und hierhin bahrain macht und
dann dass wir sie darauf kann es
passieren dass beim einzug in die
schokolade das bisher abfällt ich mache
jetzt einfach mal zwei verschiedene
vielleicht gab es auch bei machen wir
alle mit füllung und mit schokolade
dediziert man sich eingestochen und dann
habt ihr nämlich noch eine leckere
füllung mit drin und nicht einfach nur
bw drauf
[Musik]
hier könnt ihr euch auch ein bisschen
arbeit sparen und zum beispiel einfach
himbeermarmelade nehmen oder eine
marmelade eurer wahl dann müsst ihr die
früchte nicht vorher extra noch kochen
also da können da wirklich noch einiges
an zeit sparen
[Musik]
dem ist frei und den raum kuchen
schneiden 4 x 4 cm große quadrate das
sind einfach schöne handliche stücke die
aber auch gut aufnimmt ist der teller
aussehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so sieht jetzt hier das buffet aus
ziemlich gut oder
also ich finde es macht echt was her
dass auch ihr zweiter zeigt ein stempel
films herrscht ja ich mache jetzt hier
gerade die cupcakes fertig um so könnt
ihr wirklich auch alles bei
raumtemperatur stehen lassen es wird
nicht schlecht ihr könnt halt eher nicht
clown nicht klauen
ihr könnt die capex entweder so lassen
oder wirklich noch mit schokolade
überziehen oder in schokolade eintauchen
die habe ich bereits temperiert und
bisschen kokosfett rein und jetzt nehmt
ihr die einfach die haben jetzt so etwa
eine halbe stunde standen die schon sind
schon fest
ihr könnt auch kurz in den kühlschrank
stellen damit die schokolade gleich gut
festwirt und jetzt auch ich nur die
spitze ein
dann kommen noch gefriergetrocknete
hinten drauf
ok kaum habe ich ein gewisses budget
habe ich zwei mäuse hier kann das sein
eintauchen tue ich sie und ihr dürft die
himbeeren drauf machen
[Musik]
als ich habe ziehe das kuchenbuffet
fertig was jetzt noch mache ist eine
same ich habe jetzt hier bereits 500
gramm sahne in der flasche und die könnt
ihr dann auch einfach im kühlschrank
stehen lassen
hier gebe ich noch tonkarton damit rein
hier nicht so viel denn durch den druck
intensiviert sich das aroma also
wirklich ganz sparsam damit umgehen und
entweder last ist so als buffet oder er
macht wirklich der teller das könnt ihr
auch machen
und jetzt kommt hier die sahne kapsel
drauf jetzt nur ein paar mal schütteln
ich will jetzt nicht ganz steif schlagen
das reicht schon okay wenn jetzt die
verteiler anrichtet könnt ihr euch zum
beispiel die forschungslücke hinwegsehen
so eine kleine flasche füllen und dann
auf dem teller anrichten
[Musik]
und dann von jedem ein stückchen drauf
und ein kleines sahnehäubchen und dieses
wirklich erst zum schluss denn dann
sollte man es direkt sanieren perfekt
was wo finde ich es eigentlich auch eine
schöne weihnachtsfeier teil aber wir
sparen uns das jetzt denn wir haben
jetzt ein der serbe fehlt also könnte
alle kommen probieren könnt euch alle
was nehmen sie ihr könnt wenigstens was
zb sagen kann ich von dem funkerberg
aber das wird doch jetzt reichen oder
für so eine silvesterparty
du willst doch sagen haben
wie hast du die wanne sehrbrock am
besten auf dem mississippi
und ja auch
und da gibt es noch das heer soße und
wahlen könnte er die ganze nacht davon
essen
frank du kannst vertragen
du willst du bestimmt und das dessert
könnte wirklich super gut vorbereiten
und die rezepte gibt es auch sally blog
de oder in der app und ich wünsche euch
viel spaß dabei und bis zum nächsten mal
gut so und jetzt kann man noch die ganze
nachbarschaft damit füttern
denn wir haben noch keinen silvester
oder marcel stimmt ruft marcel das gibt
schokokuchen der rennt gleichung er
steht einfach direkt vor der kamera
[Musik]